dès 8 ans direct va maintenant célébrer
les animateurs les plus antipathiques
[Applaudissements]
selon la paix maintenant car vous le
savez nous sommes en direct ou par genre
direct et il faut appeler le numéro 3
qui est autre que jamais
[Applaudissements]
avec nous ce soir
mais c'est son père
assalé bougera plus sur la place gibert
trop on me signale qu'il faut passer au
deuxième match expose les gens veulent
savoir de mahler ou deux monsieur cyril
hanouna
[Applaudissements]
il est là ce soir c'est le grand arthur
le d'humeur
obama
autant vous
je crois que place à l'émotion arthur
tout de suite je vois votre souris que
vous aviez envie de reconquérir cette
place que vous aviez perdu faut dire que
ces dix dernières années j'ai été huit
fois premier